are in class you know what I'm saying
[ __ ] wears a hat date a [ __ ] did you
really kill the Queen the merrier said
you did come on pastor him daddy of
course she did now this is what a badass
holy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] happened to you
watch your head so like [ __ ] up
captain Avery didn't write holier than
now Avery got the right of it and thanks
for reminding Debbie you were really
[ __ ] up round on the house ok thanks
least I Mitch I mean since you did the
captain's Dan maybe yeah but the [ __ ] is
that like a paratrooper for pete's sake
prime captain's been saying that for
year uncle ken's the last one crazier
than a bag full of stars oh yes yes some
of the fog condensers but the
campgrounds got to be screwed listen
it's sure and find someone whereas the
reward bachelors give you the plank
ain't uh-huh hey I like we have its
homes thanks [ __ ] the whole that is
what we're doing ok let's look for our
God can I let me guess before Ben luck
it's gonna be all the way across the
[ __ ] Island I would you bet i'm so
tired of them sending me that God knows
where he says
ouches anyways hows I've on down tonight
gap that's good hey where the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] that's closest I guess
okay evil hacker what the [ __ ] he is
maniacal and I go crazy where is he
little bidding where I should get new
cool world I don't really know me i get
autumn a charm so I like six bucks the
[ __ ] okay the [ __ ] is going on here
looks like my wife's house Jesus okay
we're like that right there I keep the
hazmat suit on you Eva nope not that
cool looking just because it's [ __ ]
like it's just nice and i worry about
radiation Hey ok ok so what do I do in
here looking for a body can I get in
this [ __ ] what is that oh great Harper
saucer uncle can't sucking alive she she
knows corpses hear from me [ __ ] you are
crazy your nephew match he was always a
smart glad to hear what sure you're
coming and I thought that's you trumping
around me I haven't reset my quick do
what you can with
look that I'm just going to have to use
it
ok got got
the [ __ ] what's going on here
what to have my quest defend the visitor
center oh they're getting sworn up
f it is getting vodka
Hey look at look at this borough Nick
just tearing them a new [ __ ]
bothering anybody now God get gettin
okay let's next no be here any time now
ok
seems to be growing well I'm looking for
[ __ ] oh I hear them I hear the HUD
[ __ ] dad I should have put them up here
what is that got a head rolling holy
[ __ ] that is [ __ ] out that is dark
even for me now [ __ ] nick is hey over
here he got his that [ __ ] Gao it move
here here
where's Annette okay hey there that's
crazy Mitch was a good boy to sit before
you attract more mm-hmm hmm Mitch sent
me to bring you this is my home and I
mm-hmm how about this I'm not at oh my
god okay okay
bring it on island hey my boy he
actually did it did what chase me from
my home we should dump him in the harbor
you're really not grateful ah here it's
a getaway sticks out for Harambee